power
is not a birthright
it's earned with teeth
and claws
and sacrifice
savagery wins wars
if you're strong enough to seize it
this new kingdom will be yours
for generations kings and queens have
reigned well
over mambo
a bountiful eden far south of cebu
[Music]
but they now face the greatest threat to
their long rule
a rebel army is rising from the shadows
led by mamutzi commander of the damned
the abundant land fuels her savage ranks
[Music]
she now has enough soldiers to lay siege
to the kingdom
no more hiding in the darkness eating
scraps
[Music]
mamutsi wants the lion's share
she wants it all
she wants the throne
the king had nothing to fear until now
[Music]
the tide is turning
but reigning queens do not surrender
lightly
perhaps a truce
only a fool could believe such nonsense
[Music]
time to reveal the full force of her
hidden army
[Music]
wait
sets her unstoppable virus loose on eden
[Music]
her new regime feeds on fear
and violence
you will all now bow to me
under mamootsi's wretched reign life in
the kingdom
is about to change for everyone
pooler rules the forest
[Music]
the beating heart of the rome
her torn ear just one of a decade's
worth of scars
from battles fought and battles won
not born into royalty poula works
hard for her dominion
but her success is marred by tragedy
has only one surviving heir
this season could be her final chance to
further her legacy
she will be strong and ready
the advantage of high position in
paradise
there's always a seat at the high table
hmm
sheer will earns this humble born her
wealth
a firm grip ensures she keeps it
hide your riches
and eat fast
thieves are everywhere
every bite makes pula stronger
[Music]
but the truly wise know when to yield
[Music]
let the tyrants take their tax
there's plenty more where that came from
but dark times are coming
shattered monarchs drift in fragments of
their former prides
but three stubborn warriors remain in
the promised land
led by seija with only half a tail
[Music]
the sisters of the matata pride are
stranded
their family is scattered
but their will is far from broken
[Music]
[Music]
must rebuild her pride from the ground
up
[Music]
one little piggy at a time
[Music]
she has her own hidden secret
[Music]
six young heirs
future kings and queens
the foundations of a new empire
her sisters share the burden
[Music]
and the babysitting
a relentless onslaught of tiny teeth
their hunger bodes well for the pride's
[Music]
fortunes
[Music]
if seja can keep them alive and teach
them some manners
[Music]
this ravenous horde will one day rule
the kingdom
[Applause]
[Music]
the balance of power can shift in an
instant
[Applause]
but there's always one who swaggers with
ease through the wreckage
[Applause]
blue eyes the most charming leopard in
the row
he's making his rounds staking his
claims
quite the perfect specimen
[Music]
[Music]
he didn't really feel like warthog
anyway
blue eyes is not here for food
he's here for pula
[Music]
she only has eyes for him
vanity aside
[Music]
he is proud and strong
[Music]
and pullers best chance to further her
bloodline
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
with him by her side her legacy could
last
for generations to come
[Music]
the young
are the future
say how pride grows stronger every day
these cubs will be warriors
but for now they depend on their mothers
for everything
protect them at all costs
[Music]
inside their crash the world is safe
but there's always one born bolder than
the rest
[Music]
adventure lures the curious cub away
from his mother's cautious eye
he's yet to learn the dangers of the
wild
an innocent spirit in a ruthless world
ah
[Music]
[Music]
oh
a mother's intuition is seldom wrong
a head count confirms
one cub is missing
[Music]
ceja issues a call to arms
where is he
search as they may their efforts are in
vain
blue eyes has seemed to rap
[Music]
a mother's grief means nothing to him
[Music]
it's just an easy meal and one less
future rival
[Music]
has not only lost a valuable soldier
but a son
[Music]
rain cannot cleanse a wicked world
[Music]
but here in mumbo it does reset the game
[Music]
in this kingdom water is the real power
all right
[Music]
the new season delivers all pooler ever
[Music]
wanted
[Music]
[Music]
this is what cd
welcome to the world my little one
pooler's destiny now rests on your tiny
shoulders
blue eyes is not to be trusted
he's killed his own cubs before
[Music]
cooler cannot risk his dark side again
only he knows why he would kill his own
poola has got what she needed from blue
eyes
now she must protect her investment
leave us alone
you are no longer welcome
matsiti is all that matters now
[Music]
keep her safe pooler
[Music]
[Music]
carry her gently from her violent
father
from everyone until she can hold her own
[Music]
[Music]
uh
reign begins with chaos
the minions patrol every corner of the
kingdom
the orders are simple no one
is above her rule
everyone will pay a price
most would cower in the presence of this
dragon
but mamutse sees only opportunity
[Music]
use the beast
[Music]
let him do the dirty work
now take our share
[Music]
even dragons will serve the tyrant
she will win this tug of war
to get ahead
there is always more to steal
until she conquers everyone
the matata prides loss hardens their
resolve
[Music]
the sisters nurture their surviving cubs
[Music]
one day they will take on tyrants
together
but until then they will trust
no one
drifting vagabond out of place in the
new regime
does not know him nor his intentions
he could offer protection
perhaps even a quick path to the throne
but at what price
he could kill all their remaining cubs
the sisters can't risk losing another
[Music]
um um
their decision is clear
[Music]
but the wounded hopeful still begs for
acceptance
he needs them more than they need him
but sejah cannot take the chance
their new dynasty is far too important
these warrior sisters will build their
empire
on their own
so
[Music]
matsidi does not have the benefit of the
queen's guard
[Music]
but she does have a devoted role model
[Music]
pula is her protector
her provider she will teach her
everything she needs to know
[Music]
martini already shares her mother's
[Music]
spirit
curious and bold
a young assassin eager to explore her
forest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
world
[Music]
[Music]
she has so much to learn
savor these precious moments
danger is only ever a footfall away
a single hyena is a very bad omen
where there's one there are always more
pooler knows the kingdom's tyrants
[Music]
but this is moziti's first encounter
they will be here soon
quick
hide
your tyrant queen may think herself a
royal
but you are a wretched spy
we still own the forest
[Music]
[Music]
where are you little one
did i teach you well
[Music]
pooler is wise and strong
a self-made noble who earns her power
[Music]
if mozidi follows her mother's footsteps
one day she will inherit this world
[Music]
but the walls are closing in
flood waters surround the kingdom
now just an island in botswana's great
delta
ah
realm welcomes a new cat
this is no place for a cheetah not
now
cured in by the promise of plenty to
feed her three cubs
this place certainly seems like heaven
to this family
but little does she know
mammotsy's rotten clan sees everything
[Music]
this land is no eden
for anyone but then
the hostile welcome exposes her horrible
mistake
[Music]
this young mother has led her family
into hell
now they're trapped on an island
ruled by tyrants
but if she navigates this nightmare
she could stake her own claim to the
savage kingdom
[Music]
you